welcome to this video playing a new
five-minute game against true Shanghai
probably completely wrong pronunciation
from China and let's play the chabanenko
sloth always some like that line have
played it too many times in the past and
I mean in real in in tournament chess b3
the old way to play that yeah maybe not
the right word see five or so another
popular option e 6 or 97 don't know yeah
i forgot a lot of lot of detailed
knowledge that i had about this but i
don't think that c5 in this spot is 22
worrying yeah the question is should i
take it now
it's probably not too bad not sure
Bishop age five he might play d4 yeah
this is son in fact them an interesting
idea to set up this double pong
formation to make it too difficult to
black to play e5 but then on the other
hand it's a double pole and it can can
be a problem because you lose some
flexibility with your own pawns hmm how
to play now
hmm not easy I don't really like this
knight on f6 and like to play the F palm
not easy not easy to to find a good good
plan okay this is a sort of a nothing
moves I admit it now in this position is
quite quite resilient but I'm not quite
not to show what what I should do yes I
was expecting that it's playing it for
next
I want to transfer this night on c7 mc7
it covers b5 quite often I'm the pier
sacrifice on be 5 as a dangerous idea ah
maybe you can can even do that and I
cannot cannot do that at the mood okay
he allowed tonight c7 ok let's try to
set up a solid defensive position on the
queenside this is really hard to crack
Knight f6 three forms one idea he can
can triple or whatever on the e-file i'm
covering c7 cameras it
can even set up this awakens
confirmation and it's not not really a
thread on the other hand it sir it's a
position where I can I cannot do
anything ever just standing here can
maybe maybe I can prepare you for effort
the only are the only big idea
hmm yeah there's no way to make any
progress with with black yeah let's just
shovel after is played f3 I can I can do
something actually I just an unnoticed I
can put the night on age 5 and try to
play age 65 no this is an idea but ok
you can I can just just grab that with
the night Oh with the bishop yeah
probably probably with the night
no is closing it and tries to decide the
game on them on the kingside this some
surprises me it's really possible to
just win on the queenside okay if ad on
the kingside I mean let's say transfer
pieces if it takes on d505 I get e six
for the night and this is quite nice
actually how do you define that for now
with King g3 and 85 was really a big big
mistake no I'm I'm better even
Luke takes all night takes us are quite
strong threatens the ton of discoveries
Queen H 394 Knight f3 everything okay
what is winning now and I'd lie to you
form probably or what all 96 96 96 wins
good night for our queen edge form okay
just taking edge for a needs to give the
Queen resign yeah this was a pure
defense all the time but here really
really played here here white is just
better of course I can just sit and wait
and he played the the very strange move
85a fibers I don't know why why would
you close up the Queen side where you
when we're you're better and now the
question he white is still better after
this I mean I cannot do anything but
after this I'm not so sure already
because now i get to e6 with my night
and how do you ever open the position
the night is only six it's oops yeah
just f-4s another mistake but okay 96
with the night placed yet always a text
those pawns and he's in a position where
he's got the good bishop but the good
Bishop has got 11 deficit of course it
cannot protect your pawns and I'm just
playing Queen age 68 and I'm the only
one with an idea white what's only at da
sh for h5 and this is not easy to play
or frankly speaking impossible to play
he can he can certainly draw if he plays
accurately but just one or two bad moves
and you can easily be punished and he
Bishop f3 it was one of them played in
one second Queen h6 just and now it's
gone yeah now g5 was even stronger now
you could play G for a reg form and
after the subsides and so one yeah I
don't know am I played something
probably played something badly some
some bad moves about here maybe I need
to go e five now immediately this could
be a could be a way to go to be a bit
more active yeah probably if it doesn't
have an immediate defect then this is
probably what I should do this also
prevents f4 and make sure that I have
something in the center the in the game
it was very nice for what yeah thanks
for watching